-We're hanging out with
Joseph Gordon-Levitt now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
It is time for Joe and I to do
the "Face It Challenge."
Now, here's how it works.
Each round, I'll draw a card,
which will tell us
what face we both have to make.
We'll look in our mirrors,
make our faces,
and then reveal them on
the count of 3.
We'll stare at each other
for 10 seconds
while trying to hold our faces.
The first person to
crack a smile,
laugh, or break the face loses.
Let's see what
our first face is.
Here we go.
Okay, we have to do the --
a bad driver's license photo.
Alright, now,
we'll take a moment
and we'll make our faces
behind our mirrors.
A bad driver's license photo.
And on the count of 3,
we'll reveal.
1, 2, 3.
[ Laughs ]
[ Ding ]
♪♪
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, this next face
we have to make --
the world's happiest dog.
-These are good.
Your writers upped their game.
-Yeah, the writers are
on fire, man.
The world's happiest dog.
Here we go.
Get ready.
-Okay. Okay.
-3, 2, 1.
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
You had a prop.
You had a stick -- finger stick.
-Oh, yeah, man.
Was it a stick?
I just thought it was
someone's hand.
I thought he was happy because
he was mangling a person.
[ Both laugh ]
-Rusty, where did you
find that hand?
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-Oh, this is a good one.
Alright, let's do another one.
This one is dead eyes.
-Dead eyes.
-Like dead, like I'm playing
the corpse on "NCIS"?
-No, no, no, no, no.
I think just, like --
There was that movie,
the roller coaster,
the Santa Claus roller coaster,
where -- "The Santa Express,"
maybe?
"Polar Express."
-Oh, yeah.
-They didn't really figure out
the eyes in that one,
so all the people's eyes
were a little off.
So get in that headspace.
-Okay, okay.
-You ready? 3, 2, 1.
[ Laughs ]
[ Buzzer ]
♪♪
Just a little. Just a little.
-That's the face.
That was the face
all the kids had.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You saw that film.
Alright, here we go.
Let's do the last one here,
final round.
This one is worth
a million points.
-[ Laughs ]
-This is -- Oh, this is good.
Bass player feeling the groove.
-Hell yeah. All right.
-Bass face, basically.
Bass face.
Bass player feeling the groove.
3, 2, 1.
♪♪
[ Ding ]
-The accompaniment.
The accompaniment helps.
-Joseph Gordon-Levitt,
everybody!
Season 2 of his YouTube series,
"Create Together,"
premieres April 22nd.
Get involved with that.